wissen sie noch wann sie zuletzt im kino
waren
oder erinnern sie sich an ihrem ersten
schultag solche fragen stellt man sich
zwischendurch und sie beglücken oder
bringen uns je nachdem
zum verzweifeln wir erinnern oder
vergessen scheinbar beliebig ob wir
wollen oder nicht
was aber passiert eigentlich wenn wir
vergessen oder eben erinnern
und warum erinnern wir uns daran dass
wir etwas vergessen haben
die philosophin christine ab beschäftigt
sich von berufs wegen mit dem vergessen
der theaterwissenschaftler mats staub
wiederum bietet menschen zu erzählen und
schafft so erinnerungs räume
beide sind sie zu gast bei katja
gentinetta christina habt mats staub
welchen roman haben sie zuletzt gelesen
ich lese immer mehrere bücher parallel
und die ganze dass wir jetzt den
bücherregal gestellt habe ich ordne sie
so noch diese behauptung das war jetzt
von carlowitz korken stärken und das
hatten sie sofort im kopf das war klar
sie mussten nicht lange suchen
das ist jetzt so weit ich jetzt eben
mein büchergestell so lese datum
organisiert und da ist das letzte
exemplar ist das letzte was ich gelesen
habe um das habe ich so als bild von mir
männer technik im bücherregal sozusagen
rief ena
ja ich weiß gott erschrocken weil ich
frage weil tatsächlich immer mehrere
bücher parallel auf einem büchertisch
liegen und nicht nach dem tisch sondern
überall in der wohnung verteilt die
letzten bücher die ich gelesen habe
handeln von kommen
das waren verschiedene biografien also
nicht literarische europa aber ich habe
diese bücher sehr gern gelesen und das
hat mich dann auch verwiesen auf
literarische texte von komm ich selber
die ich mir jetzt auch wieder vernehmen
es ist ja interessant was man so bei
dingen die eigentlich präsent sind und
die man eigentlich gerne macht nämlich
lesen dass es plötzlich weg ist was man
tut also das erinnern geht ja nicht
immer auf kommando das wollte ich
einfach mal testen wie immer eine
spannende frage
aber wir reden ja heute wirklich
erinnern und vergessen nicht nur im
alter
sondern auch ganz grundsätzlich kritisch
sind philosophie an der universität
zürich im moment sie beschäftigen sich
intensiv mit dem thema vergessen wenn
ich an meinen und vergessen denke dann
denke ich eigentlich eher an die
disziplinen psychologie und neurologie
bereich nicht mal so um dass unbedingt
an die philosophie was erinnert denn die
was interessiert die philosophie am
vergessen nun es ist spannend dass
dieser eindruck so verbreitet ist dass
das vergessen kein thema der philosophie
ist in meinen augen ist vergessen gerade
aus der perspektive der philosophie
äußerst spannend und faszinierend allein
schon die tatsache dass wir feststellen
können dass wir vergessen ist ein
faszinosum dass wenn man darüber
nachdenkt und das einbezieht ins denken
viele folgen hat sowohl für die
theoretische philosophie für fragen der
theoretischen philosophie als auch für
fragen der praktischen philosophie und
ich denke einblick in die philosophie
geschichte zeigt auch dass viele
philosophen und philosophin seit der
antike bis in die gegenwart sich nicht
nur mit dem erinnern beschäftigt haben
sondern auch tatsächlich mit dem
vergessen und sich daran abgemüht haben
sich zu fragen was ist vergessen wie
können wir es ins denken mit einbeziehen
wasser was interessiert die praktische
philosophie nun wie gesagt wenn man sich
überlegt wie spannend es ist dass wir
fähig sind tatsächlich festzustellen
dass wir etwas verlieren dass uns etwas
weg geht das heißt wir können uns selber
feststellen dass wir einen namen nicht
mehr haben und wir haben ihn ja eben
nicht mehr wie finden den autorennamen
ich würde den buchtitel dann ist es eine
äußerst komplexe denkfigur dass wir
etwas abwesend das vergegenwärtigen
können als abwesenden und für die
praktische philosophie ist nur schon die
tatsache dass wir ständig dinge
verlieren dass wir nicht alles im griff
haben nicht alles behalten können hat
konsequenzen
dahingehend dass wir uns fragen müssen
was ist wirklich wichtig was wollen wir
behalten und was können wir verlieren
ohne probleme wir müssen ständig
priorisieren und dass das so ist und wie
dringend diese frage ist das ist eine
konsequenz aus der beschäftigung mit
vergessen
ganz anders gefragt sind sie selber dann
auch quasi ein übungsobjekt in ihrer
philosophie die sich selbst ich würde
sagen dass wir alle ständig vergessen
und damit anschauungsobjekte sind für
diese forschung die ich betreibe ja was
staub sie sind künstler sind
ursprünglich auch theaterwissenschaftler
dramaturg seit bald zehn jahren machen
sie kunstprojekte ausstellungsprojekte
internet projekte zum thema erinnern was
interessiert denn sie erinnern mich
fasziniert schon dass es eben nicht so
klar zum greifbar ist also man hat es
nicht ganz in der hand
es besteht immer nur aus fragmenten und
die muss man sich dann zusammensetzen um
eine geschichte zu erzählen und mich
interessieren schon sehr stark immer die
geschichten die jemand erzielen hat und
natürlich kommt dann darf wagen spielen
was ist mit der wahrheit war das
wirklich so aber nicht interessiert
erstmals den menschen der gegenwart und
was dir für deine vergangenheit
mitbringt und wie der heute damit liegt
allerdings es könnte ja auch interessant
sein die menschen überhaupt auch nach
ihren aktuellen geschichten zu fragen
aber sie wollen ja bewusst die
vergangenen geschichten hervorholen
die schon hervorholen aber eben nehmen
bezug setzen zum leben heute also nicht
schon dann stark präsenz der
vergangenheit in der gegenwart was was
hat das aus einem menschen gemacht und
von daher ist das immer so ein
wechselspiel unter denen kann man ja nur
heute was eben auch dazu führt dass man
interpretiert und nicht unbedingt immer
sagen kann wie es wirklich gewesen ist
und stellen sie das fest was christina
abgesagt hat dass die leute erinnern
dass sie etwas vergessen haben kommt das
vor das kommt häufig vor dass kommt aber
natürlich auch das plötzliche auftauchen
wo das ist ja irgendetwas was ist heute
nicht richtig begreift haben nicht immer
wieder fasziniert plötzlich taucht etwas
auch man konnte nicht wirklich sagen ich
will das jetzt noch wissen auch wir
kamen ins gespräch und plötzlich die in
die augen auch man spürt ein anderer
ausdruck und eine erinnerung ist wieder
da wo es die hergekommen
er hatte philosophie eine erklärung
dafür nein keine erklärung der für sie
hat viele sie versuchte zu beschreiben
und zu fassen und sie kommt natürlich
auch in grenzen gerade dort wo dieses
unwillkürliche erinnern mit ins spiel
kommt mein marcel proust mit dieser
suche nach der verlorenen zeit denke das
ist diese szene die alle kennen mit der
madeleine mit diesem model ein gebäck
das dann in den teer getaucht wird und
dann kommt diese erinnerung hoch und
zunächst weiter protagonist ja noch gar
nicht warum jetzt plötzlich so ein
wohlgefühl empfindet und dann
reflektiert er tatsächlich darüber
versucht nochmals und dann langsam
entwickelt er ja seine kindheit
erinnerung die ihm eben dieses
behagliche gewordene gefühl vermittelt
und beschreibt es dann als monetär also
und willkürliches erinnern und man sagt
er hat das so als begriff in die theorie
eingeführt natürlich schon vorher
darüber nachgedacht wurden aber er hat
es wunderbar gefasst
das heißt es wird etwas in gang
gesetzespaket wahrscheinlich auch bei
ihren leuten es wird etwas in gang
gesetzt und weil etwas in gang gesetzt
wird passiert dann mehr kommt mehr hoch
verständlich so fest wir haben gibt eine
andere form von madeleine das thema das
projekt ist also einerseits vielleicht
ich bin der überbringer madeleine
andererseits gibt es ja immer quasi eine
einen speziellen zugriff ich glaube man
kann nicht einfach planlos erinnern oder
das glaube ich führt dann nicht so weit
und das hat sicher dazu beigetragen dass
die leute dann plötzlich mehr wissen als
sie zuerst denken häufig höre ich am
anfang wenn ich leute fragen möchte sie
mitmachen
aber ich weiß was nicht bevor wir das
erinnern der einzelpersonen sprechen
weil mir noch einen ganzen kurzen moment
war der philosophie kristina bach ist
für aristoteles war das erinnern ja
einordnen und so gesehen auch ein akt
der vernunft und viel später wurde das
vergessen ein teil der aufklärung und
die aufstellung ist ja auch die vernunft
wahnsinnig hoch hebt können sie uns
helfen nun so ganz unterschiedlich ist
der zugang nicht bei aller
verschiedenheit gerade in bezug auf das
vergessen ist es äußerst spannend dass
eben gerade aristoteles
der schrift erinnern und wieder erinnern
hervorhebt dieses staunen dass ich
vorhin auch erwähnt habe was die
philosophie seit der antike umtreibt
eben dass der mensch feststellen kann
dass er vergisst dass wir vergessen und
erinnern das ist für aristoteles nichts
außergewöhnliches dass sagt er das
machen die tiere ebenso wie die menschen
aber was den menschen auszeichnet nach
aristoteles ist eben diese fähigkeit
über das erinnern und vergessen
nachzudenken und das heißt festzustellen
dass wir vergessen das ist das ganz
besondere und für die aufklärer ist eben
genau dieser aspekt des vergessens auch
interessant also kommt schreibt in
seiner anthropologie in praktischer
hinsicht sagt er nun gut wir finden
heraus was da irgendwie in unserem
gehirn nerven an erinnerungsfähigkeit
und vergessen passiert lassen wird dass
das sagt er explizit das macht keinen
sinn
aber wir stellen fest wir haben die
möglichkeit dinge einzublenden oder
auszublenden und er konzipiert einen
anderen vergessens begriff der aber
schon seit der neuzeit auch wieder
aufgenommen wird und sagt diese
feststellung dass wir feststellen können
dass wir vergessen das ist eine tatsache
das ist keine spekulation
also fragen wir uns was wollen wir in
den blick nehmen und was nicht und
trainieren das und die aufklärer und
eben schon die neuzeitlichen denker sind
wir sehr viel positiver gegenüber dem
vergessen eingestellt als gegenüber dem
erinnern dass überrascht heutige
menschen oft wenn ich das sage weil sie
sagen ja das ist dass sich die große
möglichkeit des denkens zu sagen was ist
wichtig was nehmen wir in den blick ich
gebe ein ratschlag sich auch und ihr
haben wir den mut selber zu denken heißt
haben wir den mut vorgelaufen die pfade
zu verlassen und unsere und wirklich
selber zu denken damit so zu vergessen
was wir gelernt haben oder was man uns
versucht hat mit zu geben ja das war ein
großer großer wichtiger punkt dass man
das neuzeitliche denken eben gesagt
haben na gut
dieses erinnern was im mittelalter der
inhalt von wissensvermittlung war auf
möglichst viel auswendig zu lernen
das lassen wir hinter uns und um
wirklich kreativ neu denken zu können
muss man vergessen
nicht mehr erinnern nicht schulaustausch
erinnern und kann führt das durch und
gleicht ein beispiel wenn wir diesen
juristischen satz denen im zweifel für
den angeklagten ganz spielt das konnte
in dieser schrift in dieser anthologie
in praktischer hinsicht durch und sagt
wenn wir diesen allgemeinen prinzip
ihren satz ernst nehmen dann müssen wir
in gewissen momenten sehr viele
emotionen ausblenden auf weg der
rachegelüste betroffenheiten um eben zu
sagen nein weil ich es gut finde muss
sich von all dem abgesehen abstrahieren
und vergessen abstraktion ist eine form
von vergessen für die aufklärung und
jetzt doch mal was kant hat ja quasi
noch gesagt in euro neurologie vergessen
gehen auch wer kann heute leben könnte
er das erscheint nicht sagen müsste er
sich ja damit beschäftigen deshalb die
frage an sie wie nahe sind sie an der
neurologe weit weg sind sie
sie können sich ja dieser vorstellung
forschungsergebnissen nicht entziehen
nämlich an
es gibt wenn man die philosophie
geschichte anschaut 2 vereinfacht gesagt
zwei definitionen von vergessen dass
eine die eine definition sagt vergessen
ist verlieren in irgendeiner art
verlieren der dinge und ich denke weder
die neurologie noch die philosophie kann
das genau erklären wir stellen es aber
fest dass es so ist und es gibt viele
untersuchen dazu es gibt theorien dazu
die zeit eine rolle spielt genetische
veranlagungen also da gibt es
verschiedene theorien die philosophie
würde ich sagen hat da keine gut
begründete oder naturwissenschaftlich
beweisbare antwort aber die andere sache
ist eben zu sagen gut wir vergessen
tatsächlich und wir wir sprechen vom
weglassen von den strategien die wir im
denken haben einzublenden auszublenden
zu priorisieren selektiv vorzugehen und
das interessiert die philosophen und da
kann man dann verschiedene formen von
vergessen unterscheiden definieren also
diese aktive teil der französischen
philosophen kann es auch positiv
dieser teil ist für die philosophie
interessant und auch für den euro
auch für die neurologie aber ich würde
sagen die neurologie versucht natürlich
zu erklären wie funktion
etwas was sind die bedingungen für das
denken und da ist die frage welcher
philosophischen richtung man man
angehört aber ich würde sagen die
philosophie kann da keine endgültigen
antworten geben aber sie kann eben sagen
was es heißt dass wir vergessen
darüber kann sie sich gedanken machen
wir wollen ja weiter denken deshalb
wollen wir gar keine letztgültigen
antworten noch eine frage an sie auch
aus der philosophie mats staub für
platon saß die erinnerung im gehirn für
aristoteles im herz wem würden sie dem
zustimmen mit ihren erfahrungen
eindeutig beiden also es gibt es gibt
wohl ein emotionaler sich und ein
rationales ich so und die kann denke ich
mich auch sehr unterschiedlich sichere
ihnen sind möglicherweise immer wieder
mal in widerstreit und quasi waren zu
einer geschichte zusammen zu finden
also ja ich möchte nicht balken amt ist
sie sind kein schiedsrichter jetzt
schauen wir doch uns jetzt mal an wie
sie arbeiten damit wir das bisschen
sehen wie es mit diesen erinnerungs
geschichten die sie produzieren vor sich
geht
sie haben 50 leute gebeten ihnen zu
erzählen was ihnen mit 21 wichtig war
was sie getan und was sie unterlassen
haben drei monate später haben sie
denselben menschen die aufnahme
vorgespielt und dabei ihre reaktion
befindet
das ist eine dame aus diesem projekt sie
sagt ihr leben war einfach sie immer
noch da damit ist sie glücklich wenn sie
sagt ihr leben war einfach hat sich ja
einfach weniger erinnerungen absolut
nicht mehr
sie ist eine der damen die sehr weit
zurück blickt das ist der erste
interessante punkt das ist ganz
verschiedenen distanzen gibt dem projekt
also man muss zuerst rechnen man man man
21 und das ist das jahr darüber dass ich
die leute dann befrage also eine wende
zum quasi irgendwo in die
erwachsenenwelt staaten aufbruch
loslösung vom bisherigen das
wahrscheinlich zu den ausgangspunkt und
bei ihr ist was über 50 jahre her
und trotzdem konnte sie sehr präzise
dinge dazu sagen und ich fand das ist
dann immer so das schlussbouquet also
die leute hören sich hat man sie lange
zu ihm ansieht die reaktionen der
erinnerung eben in der gegenwart auf
jedem gesicht und ganz zum schluss gibt
es noch diesen kommentaren und 7 gerade
weil ihr gesehen hatten
das ist wunderbar wenn man am schluss
sagen kann okay es war einfach das ist
gelungen
die tatsache dass die leute sich dass
die erst mal erinnern und sich dann noch
mal selber sehen das ist ja wie eine
doppelte eine verdoppelung der
erinnerung sind die menschen dann anders
wenn sie sich nochmal sehen als beim
ersten mal muss es erzählen und sie
würden sich dann also sie wissen
eigentlich wenn sie dann nach drei
monaten wieder kommen dass jetzt ihre
geschichte höhere in konzentrierter form
meistens geht das so acht bis zehn
minuten
sie wissen nicht was genau kommt und
meist schenken haben weil es ist
geschnitten habe und auch die
reihenfolge vielleicht ändern das ist
und es ist schon noch ahnt was da alles
passieren kann also erstmal ist halt
schon wieder zeit vergangen es ist
durchaus schon ein bisschen ein anderer
mensch geworden und dann ist für mich
die reaktion oft nicht so abschätzbar
wie werden die leute wirklich darauf
reagieren weil ja immer sehr vieles auch
nicht vorkommt aber dann durchaus eben
in der emotion noch da ist was
vielleicht auf der text gar nicht
erzählt wurde bringt nochmal andere
bilder hoch und gut der titel dieses
gesicht und das ist jetzt mal eigentlich
so eine kleine ja ein kleines abenteuer
dass mich auch sehr gut macht haben sie
das gefühl nach all diesen tagen ja
inzwischen hunderte von menschen nach
ihren erinnerungen befragt stellen sie
da gewisse muster fest dass immer wieder
ähnliche dinge kommen oder ähnliche
projekt das ähnliche prioritäten gesetzt
werden ist das sehr individuell
also erstmal bin ich erst auf der suche
nach dem individuellen also wenn den
menschen aus einzelnen der irgendeine
wirklich eigene geschichte hat
und natürlich gibt's dann verbindungs
punkte was jetzt zum 21 habe ich
vielleicht an die 100 leute gefragt und
wenn man aber dann schaut's aus es soll
so eine galerie werden durch die durch
die jahrzehnten habe ich von den
jahrzehnten jetzt doch noch nicht so
viel gelernt und operationen der schwer
zu vergleichen
etwas was man jetzt bei dem projekt sehr
stark auffällt dass schon jetzt leute
die jünger sind die es vielleicht zehn
jahre zurückblicken
ein gefühl haben dass das schon wissen
die steinzeit war weil jetzt einfach so
viel technische entwicklung war dass die
vielgucker hatte ich noch nicht mal das
internet in der hosentasche wie habe ich
überhaupt erleben kann ja gerne was ich
so spannend finde an ihren projekten ist
ja auch das in dass es so deutlich macht
dass es eben nicht ist wie vielleicht
ihre frage freuen auch die erste frage
nahe gelegt hat dass man sozusagen wie
feste bilder aus dem gedächtnis heraus
holen kann sondern dass man in dem
moment in dem man dann von mats staub
befragt wird oder angehört wird muss man
eher sagen dass man nochmal entwickelt
dass man konstruiert jedenfalls wäre das
auch meine auffassung dass ebendieses
ihm jetzt wird noch mal etwas neu
erzählt und das ist ja dann bei dass man
gibt diese erfahrung noch mehr bedeutung
man versprach licht sie gibt ihnen sinn
und man nimmt sie auch noch mal ganz
ernst und gibt ihnen wert und
wichtigkeit oder auch bedeutung in dem
moment wo man noch mal eine geschichte
erzählt und ich bin zu sparen wenn man
dann drei monate später noch erhöht wie
man sie erzählt hat habe ich auch dass
man dann einerseits noch weitere
empfindungen erinnerungen wachruft und
sich selber auch so gespiegelt sieht ist
es gibt gleich dann auch differenzen
zwischen dem was man irgendwo auch spürt
in bezug auf diese vergangenheit und das
was man erzählt hat ich denke dass auch
so spannend wenn man geschichten
vergleicht unter geschwistern zb vom
selben
ergebnis dann sind die geschichten die
man dann von der genau gleichen
festlichkeit oder von genau gleichen
moment völlig verschieden und ganz
unterschiedlich gewichtet und man
erfindet manchmal auch kleine dinge um
die geschichte besser zu erzählen oder
vollständiger zu machen also ich finde
dass es auch das spontan diesen erzähl
es passiert ihm jetzt sie sagen ja an
einem punkt sie haben das genau
aufgenommen sie sagen ein punkt die
erinnerung ist immer eine konstruktion
die sind auch eine fiktion
stellen sie das fest dass alle spüren
sie dass man es ein wenn es eine
konstruktion infektion ist und weil es
echt ist
aber ich würde das nicht auseinander der
in ihnen das konstruktion und das echt
das ist meistens ist es wirklich sehr
echt oder auch echt empfunden eben im
moment also man versucht sich ja eben
aus der gegenwart heraus zu erklären wie
man geworden ist und von daher denkt
jeden sehr wohl weil man sich das
erklären wenn man nur vielleicht dinge
auch weg lag dass man in einem bereich
kommt er denn fakt nicht unbedingt
entspricht also eigentlich fiktion aber
es kann trotzdem echt empfunden sein es
ist gefühl ist echt aber die geschichte
ist eigentlich ganz echt so ungefähr
werden sie das sagen ja ebenfalls
abkommen zu diesem thema was ist jetzt
war an dieser erinnerung und war es
nicht und da sind wir auf einem sehr
weiten feld also es ist sehr häufig so
dass er jedenfalls jetzt beim projekt um
die leute zählt haben was sie von ihren
großeltern wissen dass ich später
rückmeldung bekommen was ich da erzählt
habe ist teilweise wirklich falsch ich
habe das gemeint dass ihr so sei weil
ich mir das ebenso zusammen gedichtet
habe aber das wird man anders tun als
ein teil ist zusammen dichten weil man
eben nicht mehr alles hat er interessant
ist ja auch das erinnerungen irgendwann
mal dass ich das stellen sie an ihren
projekten bestimmt auch fest und
vielleicht auch in der forschung das
erinnerungen und vergessen dass das
irgendwann sich zu ganz festen
geschichten verfestigt also dass man
versichern ihnen dass man auch wenn man
selber erzählt man kennt eigentlich den
erzählfluss schon
es hat sich total verfestigt und es ist
nicht mehr viel ist passiert nicht mehr
dieses dieses spontane was sie vorher
angesprochen haben
was ist dann ist das noch erinnern oder
ist das schon etwas anders anders
also ich mich sind das diese anekdoten
die ich nicht so mag ich so und auch mit
diesem projekt 21 gerade bei den älteren
leuten die noch kriegserfahrungen haben
war das auch ein bisschen ein trick sie
quasi von diesen angefangen erzielen
muss den weg zu bringen dass sie einfach
nicht die geschichten erzählen können
die sie erzählen wenn sie nach der alten
zeit gefragt war sondern sagen nein nur
dieses jahr was war da eigentlich weil
ich ihnen da sehen müsst ihr euch bei
diesen storys manchmal ganz unterhaltsam
aber insgesamt bringen sie quasi
wenigsten ich bin wirklich misstrauisch
dass ich oft das gefühl haben sie
verdecken auch was nämlich das was
dazwischen war das so viel zeit um eben
überhaupt dann diese ränder dieser
geschichten wieder zu öffnen
denn wie gesagt haben sie schließen sich
und dann sind das anekdoten die
vielleicht auch gemeinschaftsbild sind
mythenbildung funktioniert so dass man
nur schon ein begriff sagen muss alle
kennen die anekdote aber wenn ich ihre
projekte verstehe
geben sie den leuten ja sehr viel zeit
und das ist etwas was das erinnern dann
auch ausbreitet es gibt verschiedene
forschungen auch dazu dass man eine
minute jetzt zum beispiel von dieser
sendung könnte eine minute danach her
erinnern und wir könnten mehrere stunden
darüber sprechen wenn wir nämlich auch
noch sagen würde welche kamera hier
welches licht wie wir uns gefühlt haben
wie sich dieser stuhl anfühlt ein tisch
das wasser aber wenn wir nur ganz kurz
gefragt werden wo wir sagen das war eine
gute sendung schlechter da sollte ich
mich gefühlt und würden uns noch auf dem
inhalt einigen aber das heißt wenn man
zeit hat kann man viel viel mehr
aktualisieren an wahrnehmung in einem
moment als wir gemeinhin tun wir lassen
wahnsinnig viel weg das ist dieses
vergessen dass in dem wir ständig uns
bewegen auch das fokussieren sie
befragen personen nach den erinnerungen
und sie zeigen dieser nach sie
beschäftigen sich mit dem vergessen und
wir haben jetzt ein bisschen gehört wenn
man es gerade unserem lebensgeschichten
geht kann man denn sagen dass wenn man
sich nicht erinnern kann wenn man
vergisst dass man keine persönlichkeit
ist wissen ab
ja das sind schwierige fragen im
zusammenhang mit alzheimer mit demenz
sind diese fragen heute aktuell und
diskutiert ich persönlich sagen ein mann
hatte eine persönlichkeit denn das
interessante ist ja dass diese menschen
auch viele erinnerungen haben es sind
nur häufig keine erinnerungen die sehr
kurzfristig gemacht wurden also
erinnerung an erfahrung dieser
kurzfristig gemacht wurden fallen weg
aber die meisten menschen haben
erinnerungen sie sind nur nicht mehr
verknüpft mit relevanz mit dem konkreten
zustand in dem man lebt
ich denke nicht dass man sagen kann dass
man die persönlichkeit verliert aber es
ist natürlich eine konfrontation mit mit
den aspekten von persönlichkeit die man
nicht im griff hat und das ist enorm
schwierig und schmerzhaft und da
verliert man natürlich einen ein teil
seiner identität die man heute als etwas
festes denkt ich glaube wir gehen häufig
davon von etwas festerem aus bei
identität oder identitäten als es
tatsächlich ist und dieser verlust eben
auch an klaren geschichten mit denen wir
uns so schnell identifizieren das
verunsichert massiv und und das stelle
natürlich solche fragen auf sie haben
jetzt gleich eigentlich auf die demenz
angesprochen eigentlich auf die
schwierigen momente aber wenn wir von
ganz normalen gesunden menschen ausgehen
haben sie das gefühl oder spüren sie das
mit den verschiedenen menschen die sie
befragen
dass in diesen erinnerungen auch ihre
persönliche geschichte und dann eben
dadurch auch ihre persönlichkeit steckt
ja so stark was nicht heißt dass eben
einen teil auch vergessen werden kann
das braucht man ja auch und ich glaube
es ist dann nicht so einem engen frage
sondern sie haben das stichwort schon
zweimal so genau was ist wichtig also
wenn man gewichtet und wie
man eben vielleicht auch wert versucht
quasi sorge zu tragen zu gewissen
erinnerung dass man sie nicht verliert
und das ist wichtig bei den leuten was
den leuten am wichtigsten in ihren
projekten was stellen sie fest
also erstmal ganz einfach eine eigene
individuelle geschichte zu haben also
damit erstellen einsichtigkeit erstellen
sie dann oft auch plötzlich fest dass
das auch eine interessante geschichte
ist also nicht interessiert ja eben
dieses sogenannte normale leben und ich
glaube es gibt dass das nicht in frage
ich immer solche leute keinen namen
haben und oft denken die wir vielleicht
ja warum ich aber dann merkt man doch
sehen wo es lohnt sich dazu zu hören
umgekehrt gibt es forschung darüber was
die leute am meisten ärgert was sie
vergessen es gibt thesen dass man namen
sehr leicht vergisst weil sie keine
verknüpfungsmöglichkeiten mit den
inhalten hat also ein name eines autos
sein buch das hat nämlich keine
eselsbrücke oder so keine hilfe aber
ansonsten tendiert die forschung so weit
ich weiß im moment auch dazu doch mit
mit relevanz auch zu argumentieren und
dass wir unseren extrem schöne momente
erinnern und die erste liebe oder in
glücklichen moment der glückliche zeiten
aber auch ein großes leid schwer das
schwierige momente dass die intensität
der durchaus ein kriterium für
erinnerungen und ich denke dass eben das
auch zuerst wahrscheinlich kommt auch
emotionen sind sehr viel stärker
vergegenwärtigen als vielleicht fakten
über das persönlich erinnern gesprochen
darüber dass relevantes er erinnert wird
aber auch darüber dass was wir erinnern
dass das in dem moment präsentiert das
ist ja ein ganz wichtiges moment beim
erinnern es wird dann wieder neue
präsent ich möchte dass es noch auf ein
ganz anderes thema zu sprechen kommen
nämlich das erinnern einer ganzen
gesellschaft
das sogenannte kollektive gedächtnis wir
werden ja derzeit gleichsam
flächendeckend an den ersten weltkrieg
erinnert wo man auch ist man liest man
hört man sieht geschichten neue
forschungsergebnisse den ersten
weltkrieg was ist eigentlich ihre
reaktion auf eine solche nennen wir es
einmal erinnerungs maschinerie meine
persönliche reaktion ist dass ich
natürlich teilnehmer an diesem medialen
angebot das ich mir diese dinge auch
noch mal anders vergegenwärtige gerade
jetzt tatsächlich wie sie sagen den dem
ersten weltkrieg
trotzdem bedarf es denke ich dann immer
anknüpfung möglichkeiten
damit dieses dieses wissen wenn man
nicht einfach überhaupt historisch sehr
interessiert ist und sich eben dann doch
auch emotional mit diesem ersten
weltkrieg verbunden fühlt braucht es
anknüpfungspunkte nicht operativ sind
und ob es alle menschen jetzt so
beschäftigt wie wir wenn wir jetzt
darüber sprechen dass das kollektiv
erinnern ist man muss durchaus an den
medienangeboten teilnehmen keil haben
das man sagen würde ja jetzt sind wir
kollektiv mehrin dann ich glaube viele
menschen sind nicht tangiert im moment
davon ganz so einig wie kommt das bei
ihnen an
diese form der erinnerung also ich bin
jetzt schon auch überrascht dass schon
jetzt noch bei januar ist nicht vorbei
und die wirklich wie viel
jetzt war über schon gezielt und welche
menge das geht jetzt ein jahr so weit
hat das er dann gleich so einen
abwehrreflex ich bin aber auch sehr
interessiert was
was lässt sich denn wirklich noch sagen
weil so aus dem kommunikativen
gedächtnis ist der erste weltkrieg
endlich verschwunden
also es gibt einfach kaum noch menschen
die da etwas erlebt haben oder überhaupt
schon mal die älteren generation wo man
noch vielleicht eben was sie mehr weiß
ist nicht mehr so spürbar
und was ich im moment zur stelle klar
man sucht gegen diese anknüpfungspunkte
man versucht vergleiche herzustellen
es ist jetzt doch sehr ähnlich heute und
das ist natürlich eine interpretation
von heute also ich weiß es nicht
jetzt hat die politik hat ja ganz
bestimmte strategien mit solchen
erinnerungen auch mit solchen qualitäten
erinnerungen umzugehen
ein wichtiges beispiel dafür ist die
wahrheits und versöhnungskommission
südafrika sie wurde 1998 eingesetzt um
die verbrechen des apartheid-regimes
aufzuarbeiten und das land zu versöhnen
schauen wir uns hier eine tagesschau
ausschnitt anfang 2001 der gesendet
wurde kurz nach der letzten sitzung
dieser kommission bischof desmond tutu
versteckt seine tränen unter dem tisch
er hört wie sich apartheid opfer mit
schilderungen von folter mord und
entführung den schmerz von der seele
reden
die kommission will endlich die wahrheit
ans tageslicht bringen
ein ehemaliger sicherheitspolitisch
demonstriert foltermethoden zu wie er
haben sich rund 7000 personen zu ihren
verbrechen bekannt und amnestie
beantragt juni in den korb der
berüchtigte killer und polizeioberst
sagte aus er habe massaker an
oppositionellen schwarzen begangen
auf befehl der regierung bothas pieter
willem botha selbst verspottete die
wahrheitskommission als zirkus der
letzte apartheids regierungschef und
spätere präsident südafrikas verweigerte
die aussage vor der kommission und
musste deswegen vor gericht
sein nachfolger wm geklärt entschuldigte
sich für das apartheid-regime doch er
habe nichts gewusst von den verbrechen
seine aussagen vor der
wahrheitskommission lisa später im
bericht streichen
aber auch der oppositionelle aliens der
afrika national congress und seine
verbrechen wurden unter die lupe
genommen
winnie mandela ex-frau von nelson
mandela wurde mord und folter
vorgeworfen
sie äußerte tiefes bedauern er bildet ja
immer noch unter die haut gehen und hier
ist natürlich weit weg von dem aber das
interessante ist schon christine ab ich
habe ja gesagt das war darauf wert
gelegt dass ist in umgangssprache ist es
die wahrheitskommission aber es eben die
wahrheits und versöhnungskommission ich
glaube was man da sieht ist das erinnern
und versöhnen irgendwie nicht so einfach
ist ist denn vergessen und versöhnen
einfacher so leicht würde ich ja immer
vergessen und erinnern nicht auseinander
halten sondern für mich sind vergessen
und erinnern immer sehr kompliziert
aufeinander verweisen ineinander
übergehend und hier haben wir natürlich
einen politischen versuch entspannten
versuch es gab vorher schon versuche in
südamerika ähnliches zu machen aber
südafrika ist bekannt geworden dadurch
dass eben gesagt haben wenn leute
gestehen was sie gemacht haben in der
öffentlichkeit dass es wurde ja über 18
monate wurde und dann noch mal sechs
monate verlängert wurde im ganzen land
verteilt gab es gerichte konnte man eben
seine taten bekennen oder auch schildern
was man erfahren musste und wenn man das
tut dann hat man die hoffnung gehabt und
es hat ein stück weit ja auch
funktioniert tatsächlich
dass man gesagt hat man versöhnt eine
gesellschaft die tief gespalten ist
wenn man schaut wie das parlament das
sich dazu durchgerungen hat diesen weg
zu gehen wie die diskutiert habe dann
gab es einfach die beiden meinung dass
man gesagt hat man muss alles
aufarbeiten was alles ans licht bringen
und die andere seite ja gesagt wenn man
das tut dann wird dieses land nicht zum
frieden kommen dann wird es nicht
schafft eine stabile gesellschaft geben
also hat man diesen mittelweg gewählt
mal gesagt man legt es offen während
einer gewissen klar begrenzen zeit und
danach soll man die möglichkeit haben
eine neue gesellschaft ist es möglich
sich sich quasi eine mine eine gewisse
zeit lang bewusst zu erinnern gefordert
zu erinnern um dann quasi ins vergessen
überzugehen ist das möglich im kopf ich
denke es ist schon möglich und es ist
kollektiver hier auch gelungen was
natürlich die frage ist was es mit den
einzelnen individuen macht und das ist
eine ganz andere geschichte
darüber wurde auch geschrieben wenn
natürlich hier auch die erwartung war
dass diese einzelnen menschen dann auch
bereit sind zu versöhnen dann ist das
ein sehr hoher anspruch der eine
gesellschaft zugunsten von frieden und
stabilität an einzelne betroffene stellt
und man kann auch sagen das hier hat
sich dem frieden der stabilen
gesellschaft ein vorzug gegeben wurde
vor gerechtigkeit also die kriterien der
gerechtigkeit argumentiert hätte hätte
es wahrscheinlich ganz andere verfahren
auch geben können man hat das eben nicht
diesen weg nicht gewählt und hier finde
ich kollektiv hat etwas funktioniert was
für einzelne aber dennoch wahrscheinlich
schwierig zu ertragen und auch zu
schlucken war
und da kann man sich fragen darf dann
ein kollektiv von diesen menschen auch
verlangen jetzt sozusagen den teppich
über ihre betroffenheit auch zu legen in
einem gewissen maß ja dafür das darf es
danach verlangen diesen teppich darüber
zu legen aber darf es davor maßstab von
den individuen verlangen dass sie diese
erinnerung nochmals hervor holen nachdem
sie möglicherweise gerne weil weg
geschoben haben
sie haben ja auch menschen interviewt in
einem alter die durchaus beide
weltkriege erlebt haben und schreckliche
geschichten erlebt haben wollten die das
noch mal erinnern sollten sie das
nochmal die gegenwart holen oder wollten
sie eigentlich lieber abstand haben
erstmal war ein abwehrreflex da aber
jeder aus der erfahrung dass sie schon
oft in die pfanne gehauen wurden
als er dann gemerkt haben da hat jemand
wirklich zu warten sie sehr gerne bereit
und ich glaube schon dass das
funktionieren kann dass man erst mal
eben etwas noch einmal hervor hat um es
dann auch beruhigte auch bei seite legen
zu lassen das habe ich jedenfalls und
festgestellt oder ich war jetzt im
sommer aber im auf dem balkan und habe
dort erstmal gespräch führt zu einem
tanz in belgrad aus eigentlich in einem
täter ort auch mit leuten gehe aber sich
eigentlich nicht direkt schuldig gemacht
haben im gegenteil aber sie waren halt
doch da und da war für mich erstmal
sowie spürbar ja wie nahe was ist und
wie schwierig das auch ist jetzt sind
noch nicht so viele jahre vergangen
es ist alles noch da trifft die leute
die täter möglicherweise im straßencafé
weiß es auch nicht
und viele haben gesagt wir haben wir
müssen das irgendwie auch arbeiten sonst
kommen wir nicht weiter also man muss es
quasi die auf den tisch legen wie ich
auch gesagt haben muss sie aussprechen
und danach kann man es beiseite legen
steckt sich eine eine große erzählung
auch dahinter nämlich die erzählen der
psychoanalyse oder die erzählung
überhaupt der psychologie die darauf
wert legt dass so etwas passiert dass
wir dadurch dass wir etwas in worte
fassen welt auch konstruieren können und
das auch in uns sich etwas löst und ich
denke das ist auch mit diesem titel
wahrheits und versöhnungskommission da
steckt natürlich ein enormer anspruch
dahinter wir haben vorhin gesagt
vorhergesagt erinnern ist auch immer
konstruieren
aber ich würde eher sagen es ist er im
deutschen hat man dann ja auch oft
gesagt eine wahrheits findungskommission
ich finde das exakte aber im englischen
war es im diffusen kommission also hier
ist man davon ausgegangen dass den
menschen alles sagen dann ist es eine
art von kartons ist eine art von
reinigung
das verdrängte dass das schändliche
kommt hervor und wenn man es angeschaut
hat dann kann man es mit zur seite legt
das ist auch eine große erzählung die in
der westlichen welt natürlich auch
bekannt ist und aber auch durchaus
kritisch beleuchtet werden kann
ja das stimmt also dass auch dieses zur
seite legen sagt jedem winter nicht
überlegen
letztlich hat man das ja auch nicht
eingriffen ich stelle es taucht dann
doch wieder auf und wie fest kann man
wirklich etwas zur seite legen
fragezeichen
aber die frage ist ja auch da hat man
als politik auch die nicht nur die
aufgabe sondern auch die verantwortung
solche prozesse zu steuern weil es gab
ja durchaus auch eine position wo man
sagt wir müssen vergessen damit ihr neu
anfangen können damit wir uns überhaupt
je wieder versöhnt oder man sagt nein
wir müssen erinnern wir dürfen nicht
vergessen
letztlich muss die politik da ihre
aufgabe ihrer verantwortung auch
wahrnehmen kann sie das ja es ist ja
spannend das sozusagen das ist auf diese
ganzen haus linie sozusagen auf der eine
pol ist zu sagen dass man alles erinnern
muss und dann legt man weg und auf der
anderen seite gibt es durch die
historischen momente wo man gesagt hat
und sich vertraglich darauf geeinigt hat
ewiges vergessen nicht mehr darüber
reden westfälische frieden nach den
traurigen krieg so schwierig einen
frieden zu etablieren man hat sich dann
auf der einigen alles was passiert ist
darf nicht mehr angesprochen werden oder
auch im spanischen bürgerkrieg im 20
jahrhundert hat man sich darauf geeinigt
nicht darüber zu sprechen was die beiden
seiten begangen haben um überhaupt die
verschiedenen parteien an einen tisch zu
kriegen das heißt wir haben beide
politischen experimente in
anführungszeichen und in beiden fällen
hat es zum teil funktioniert aber ich
würde auch sagen wie man sich dort
gerade gesagt hat natürlich sind die
spuren
wenn wir uns einigen zu vergessen dann
dann ist es nicht das ist mir einfach
weg sondern dann sprechen wir nicht mehr
da von dort sind strategien da etwas
abzuschwächen in den diskursen etwas
langsam
aus dem blick zu kriegen aber weg ist es
nicht sonst sprechen wir nicht von
vergessen ganz einfach in der schweiz
haben wir einfache fragen die wir uns
darstellen beispielsweise jubiläen ich
denke an eines der letzten großen
jubiläen 1998 die eine schweiz feiert
150 jahre bundesstaat die andere schweiz
feiert die 200 jahre mediation also die
kantone haben sich sozusagen das
jubiläum heraus gepickt das für sie
besser war
was sagt das war ein land außen was sagt
dass wir den umgang mit jubiläen aus
zunächst mal sagte ist dass wir einen
federer struktur hier das land sind das
denke ich es in der schweiz ganz stark
dass von der gemeinde ebene bis zur
bundesebene sehr viele verschiedene
lokale feierlichkeiten vorhanden sind
die mit unterschiedlichen gewichtungen
auch ernst genommen werden und zunächst
mal das vertrauen system wird hier sehr
schön gespiegelt es gibt ja auch immer
um dieses stolz und charme so und also
ich denke mal wenn sie inoffiziell
notiert wird dass man sich jetzt
erinnern will
dann sucht man natürlich eher etwas
worauf man stolz ist das ist klar
und das andere wird ein jahr vielleicht
kann er ihm aufgedrängt wenn man jetzt
in einem schwierigen gesellschaft
aufgewachsen ist das auch jubiläen
kommen vom schwierigen ereignissen in
der schweiz gibt ja eigentlich nicht
wirklich eine glaublich kollektive
charme ob schon der durchaus unsere
geschichte dinge gibt über die man sich
zu schämen kann
es gab ja schon moment ist
beispielsweise nach dem fernsehbericht
wo wir wirklich position gehabt hat oder
die ein gesagt haben das war unbedingt
notwendig und haben gesagt wir hätten
das gescheiter nie gemacht
also da merkt man schon wie eine
gesellschaft sich plötzlich spaltet
indem sie eben das stolze nicht
vergessen will und das was schon
bereitet lieber nicht lieber nicht
erinnern will
ich denke dass das was schauen bereitet
dafür was worüber man sich schämen
sollte das wird generell mehrheitlich
nicht gern erinnert die feiern die
nationen feiern das sind ihr die dinge
und die man sich gerne erinnert das
würde ich schon
auf jeden fall werden